ken jennings the most winning guy on
Jeopardy ever millions of dollars will
play Fred in jeopardy
this is the guy who won what is it's
like over two million dollars
it's a remarkable amount of my look at
this guy genius I mean I watched you on
Jeopardy
my father worships you that's what
everybody tells me
yeah the only man my grandma loves you
man you won 3.1 million something like
that in that amazing crazy right I'll
give you five thousand great Fred I
don't think Fred stands a chance against
you every time I listen to this segment
Fred like wins handily so I'm pretty
nervous but he ain't playing you not a
snowball's chance in hell all right well
let's try it what do you say and what
the hell for five grand why not well put
Fred in the isolation booth well that
can't answer the questions first
seven questions okay all right I assure
you fred has not seen them because we
know the rules you can't you know you
can't tell and and these questions were
decided upon by my staff and me okay so
let's start who was the first United
States President to die in office
William Henry Harrison what is the
second most abundant element on earth
and the principal ingredient of glass
silicon which NFL team has won the most
Super Bowls the Cowboys which Canadian
provenance is largest impatiens Ontario
sauerkraut is made from what a vegetable
who was known as the Clown Prince of the
Harlem Globetrotters for 2011 on the TV
series the Six Million Dollar Man who
did Steve Austin report to I have no
idea
I do you want to stop you want to stop
the clock okay all right 36 oh you are
awesome well I screwed up the Six
Million Dollar Man question all right
let's see how Fred does you only got two
wrong I won't tell Fred how you did I'm
gonna keep Fred I'm gonna keep it a
secret from you how Ken did let's just
say good luck I'm predicting him in
ahead of time seven out of seven around
30 seconds all right that's my
prediction here we go
60 seconds on that hook you can pass and
this kind of thing
here we go this is for $5,000 for Ken
you Freddie nothing can I've been I've
been the winner of this thing for seven
years straight all right here we go
who was the first United States
President to die in office Lincoln what
is the second most abundant element on
earth and the principal ingredient of
glass silicon which NFL team has won the
most Super Bowls Dallas which Canadian
provenance is largest in population
Ontario sauerkraut is made from what
vegetable cabbage who was known as the
Clown Prince of the Harlem Globetrotters
for 24 seasons Meadowlark lemon on the
TV series the Six Million Dollar Man who
did Steve Austin report to Oscar do you
want insolvent stop okay look at that I
don't know how the hell this gets
decided we haven't gotten too steep into
the rolls you you clocked in at 36
seconds Ken yes Fred clocked in at 36
seconds you tied on time yes you tied on
the amount of right answers Gary is is
this a tie it is there our tiebreaker
questions there there are additional
questions but I don't know how you do
them we can write down our answer you
can say it I'll write mine down he'll
write his down and we'll just hold her
outright tiebreaker let's do it
all right if either of you guys know
this you're [ __ ] genius okay here we
go on what ship did charles darwin serve
as a naturalist during a five-year
voyage in the 1830s Fred hold up your
answer first what does it say HMS Beagle
what is your say wow what did I do wrong
in school that I don't know any of them
I mean what went wrong Fred you're
impressive HMS Beagle okay second
tiebreaker because we're in a tiebreaker
situation I say let's leave it at I yeah
wine happy
I could throw you one more idea Howard I
could give you seven new questions and
we could play the game again real so
let's try this again
who did Helen Keller dedicate her
autobahns Elenin the disposable razor
blade instead of the existing straight
razor was whose brains flattened what
positions make up the battery in
baseball pitcher encounter for more than
1,000 years 794 - 1868 which city was
the capital of Imperial Japan Kyoto a
group of porcupines is called what I
don't know what is the state bird of
Texas
Meadowlark what famous Wild West legend
did Martha Jane canary grow up to be
comedy Jane that show done past okay not
going back 35 seconds your lucky night
she got three wrong but she did it in 35
seconds which is a rapid time it's quick
I don't know I don't feel good I think
Fred's got this you do yeah those are
tough but I think Fred's got this
alright let's see alright Fred I'm not
gonna tell you again how Ken did is you
know ken is a jeopardy champion
extraordinaire you managed to tie him
not only Weiss twice
there we go who did Helen Keller
dedicate her autobiography to and how
[ __ ] I can't remember nice then go ahead
the disposable razor blade instead of
the existing straight razor was whose
brainchild in 1895 alack what positions
make up the battery in baseball the
infield the pitcher catcher for more
than a thousand years 794 - 1868 which
city was the capital of Imperial Japan
Kyoto a group of porcupines is called
what I heard Texas hey Berta Texas
Roadrunner what famous Wild West legend
did Martha Jane cannary grow up to be or
canary Annie Oakley all right you want
to go back to anything stop the clock
here at a 47 seconds our friend Ken did
it in 35 see guidance and you got four
wrong he got three wrong so he is the
winner
close very close I'm not embarrassed
no you I'm not eres you should go hang
your head in shame get it go home why
should you be embarrassed Ken what do
you think that was great that was
amazing no but you beat him and you are
those were really really tough question
you were more arrogant than ever aren't
you you be friends money I gotta say
this was more exciting than winning all
those games of Jeopardy put together
[Laughter]